we've shared exactly zero tips because I
don't think Megan needs any tips about
anything Patrick J Adams tops former
suits co-star Megan markle's upcoming
milestone motherhood and we're super
happy for her you know I actually
haven't spoken to her since she's
pregnant but Megan I'm very happy for
you it's the greatest thing that ever
happened to you having a baby so we hope
everything is happy enough Patrick and
his wife pretty little liars actress
Tryon Belisario welcomed their first
child together back in October so can we
expect their daughter to one day have
playdates with babies Sussex may be at
her house et spoke with the famous
couple at the good for a laugh benefit
in LA on Friday night an event that
raised money for two organizations war
child and Anora
which support children whose lives have
been devastated by war Patrick suits
co-stars Sarah Rafferty and Rachel
Harris were among the other celebs to
hit the red carpet they told et they
were all for playdates at Megan's house
too
I have a two and a half year old and six
month old I mention a nurse for her she
control a pop on a private jet no for
your kids and why not Rafferty attended
Megan's recent New York City baby shower
and had this to say about sharing the
special moment with her and while the
Duchess of Sussex may not be returning
for the final season of Seuss it sounds
like a return isn't completely out of
the question for her on-screen husband
we're trying to figure it out and see if
it's possible if so is scheduled is
another work that's coming along is just
a scheduling thing but I'm hoping so it
depends on the story they write they got
to figure it out and if they even want
me to ask them I'm saying quiet over
here I'm pretty sure I can talk them
into tonight I will give him a little
tequila and get him to write it write it
down pinky swear he's a man of his word
I think I think he'll do it we can't
think of by without him I also really
hope that he comes back to direct that
would that would really mean a lot to me
is amazing director
[Music]